[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 174 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Oscar Hammer lee and i'm here with
my colleague mark Mendell hey Mark hey
how you doing I'm pretty good actually
excited about this week's episode yeah
I've been up since 5:00 a.m. Eastern and
now I'm in San Francisco so I don't know
what day it is but it's great
I'm so sorry mark but I'm glad that
you're out in community teaching folks
awesome stuff about a goddess I do stuff
it's cool so this week we have some
pretty cool people coming to hang out
with us we have Anne Wallace security
practice lead and Michael woman TPM of
cloud migrations both from the
professional services organization or
PSO so they're going to talk to us all
about what the PSO team does here at
Google cloud and how they help out
customers and later we've got a question
of the week about cloud build but first
let's do the cool thing of the week
[Applause]
we have many cool things what if you go
to Asia one of our co-workers Amy Unruh
built an app that uses cloud vision to
identify key features of images that are
texted to it the link is going to be in
the show notes and if you have lots of
pictures of cats or pretty plants it
will tell you all about them and it's
confidence and it's identifying them
it's a really cool example of how you
can hook up some of our ML API is to
your existing applications nice so as
many people know I really love games so
this is a specifically cloud but it was
so awesome I just thought I'd mention it
on the Google Blog cold want to change
the game design your own with Google
Play so the change the game program came
out of Google Play last year teamed up
with girls make games they're looking
for teens that want to share their game
idea and vision of the future of gaming
basically for a chance to see their game
come to life on Google Play the grand
prize winner of the challenge will win
$15,000 towards college scholarship and
$15,000 for their school or community
centers technology program which is
really awesome there's a whole bunch of
other stuff in there as well
unfortunately it is us residents only
but if you want to get involved or you
know a teen that might want to get
involved I will have a link in the show
notes to apply that sounds awesome
my other cool thing for this week is if
you saw the developer keynote at next
either in person or you watched one of
the recordings or the live stream the
game of life app that was demoed during
that keynote is still up if you want to
play with it and it's a game of life dev
Oakland yeah it's really cool I didn't
ever think of game of life as a team
sport I was thought of it as a fun
mathematical exercise but it's actually
a lot of fun when there's five teams
playing trying to out glider each other
so folks wanna check it out it's still
up there
feel free to go try it and compete
against your co-workers fantastic last
but not least again I seem to be picking
semi non cloud stuff this is a Google
search thing but it was just too
adorable to pass up I'm gonna read the
first paragraph because it's fantastic
it's not quite cat a day and we're a few
months away from the dog days of summer
but searches for pets never pause around
the world people constantly ask Google
questions about their furry friends so
there's no time like the present for a
good old fashioned oh my God look at
that little face off uh-huh
so it's basically an article talking
about how people search for about dogs
and cats and not only is an article
discussing it they made a website called
why do cats and dogs calm
talking about all the trends that people
ask about why do dogs do certain things
or why do cats do certain things such as
licking or eating or moving around or
shakes or just weird sounds that they
make my dog makes a little weird sounds
so it's a lot of fun whether you're a
cat person or a dog person I'm super
excited about that because we all know
you're a dog person
but I am definitely a cat person and I'm
sitting here according being supervised
by one of my cats and my dog is fast
asleep next to me snoring dogs are so
much better behaved sometimes why don't
we go have a chat with and and Michael
oh and get the interview going so this
week I am very excited to have two
wonderful people come and join us we
have Ann Wallace security practice lead
and Michael woman TPM of cloud
migrations joining us from the
professional the services department for
Google cloud how are you both doing
today I'm good doing great awesome well
thank you so much for joining us and
coming to talk to us all about
professional services and what it does
before we do that George tell us a
little bit about yourselves and what you
do here at Google sure my name is Ann
Wallace I'm based in the Portland office
I am currently the global security
practice lead for Google PSO or
professional services the security
practice is fairly new we spun off of
the infrastructure practice about six
months ago so I've been helping build
that out within the Americas and
globally prior to Google I spent 14
years at a major athletic company in
Portland
I had a wide roles in architecture and
engineering and when I'm not working you
can find me running very long distances
on trails and in the mountains you run
they're like ridiculously long distances
yeah 50k is 50 miles
my dog has run up to 30 miles with me I
dog barely runs like if we hit a hill
she's like it's hard no yeah I never
German Shorthaired Pointer they are very
energetic dogs Michael you want to tell
us a little bit about yourself sure
I run double ultra marathons because I
have a rambunctious three-year-old long
curly blond hair who we called the dude
so I'm constantly chasing after him
occasionally I'll chase after mountain
lions in the Berkeley Hills for
professional services I'm an
infrastructure practice lead and you
know infrastructure is kind of the
catch-all practice compute storage
networking containers app dev security
but we're beginning to spin off these
like sub practices and that's where kind
of n came in and picked up security so
outside of that I do big gnarly
migrations from on-prem to cloud from
other clouds to other clouds and yeah
I'm cloudy
yeah and actually you know
Michael and I met it's probably six
years ago outside of Google the company
I was working for he helped us do our
first cloud migration so then we just
ended up at Google together yes and I
remember debugging a custom pearl
configuration management system it was
amazing y'all said that you work for PSO
what does PSO do I mean we help
customers migrate applications and
storage around we help them in essence
move generally from on-prem to cloud
right that's like our charter you know
more recently it's been moving customers
from clouds to other clouds and setting
up kind of these hybrid environments and
you can imagine the challenges with this
I mean I think customers that are kind
of maybe sitting in the San Francisco
Bay Area that are more tech heavy have
an easier job but you know we have to
service all customers therefore you know
we can fly out to the Midwest and
service some customers there and you
know it's different challenges so yeah I
think in a nutshell that's what we do
but I think there's a little bit more to
that as well we work a lot you can think
of us as post-sale versus the pre-sales
where you have our customer engineers
and solution architects but we also
partner and very heavily with those
teams and work on solutions around
security data migration AI ml sort of
things and we also getting a lot of
customers who are wanting to figure out
how to move their VM applications to
containers so it's not just the
traditional lifted shift kind of
scenarios anymore also I speak at
several conferences a year and we're at
Google next the cloud summits and we
work pretty closely with a lot of the
themes I work very closely with a lot of
the security PMS with a lot of input
into the roadmaps for a lot of the
services and GCP services just because
of customer input to add to that like
everything kind of starts with the
customer right so the professional
service org is like the one that touches
the customer the most like we're there
we're friends with the customer like I
have dinner with the customer and then I
help them design their next generation
products so what is it a typical
engagement with a customer actually look
like where do they go like how does it
get started and then like where does it
go from there it starts with us scoping
right
starts with a dream you know
specifically a GCP it starts with the
dream of like I want to operate like
Google okay right and it just starts
there and then you kind of work
backwards and like what does that mean
it means like you know being flexible
fast deployments you know able to
iterate very quickly being secure so
like it starts there and then we kind of
work backwards and figure out like how
do we actually make it a reality
and so it's challenging right because I
mean customers are running more
monolithic applications right so they're
older and you know now they want to run
in containers and micro services and how
to get the data up there etc etc but I
wouldn't say there's really a typical
type of engagement because every
customer is so unique and brings
different challenges to us and it's not
always technical sometimes it's more
organizational that we have to navigate
through but you know sometimes the
conversations start with us sometimes
they start before us again working with
maybe a solution architecture team or
customer engineers and then we get
pulled in when they went a little bit
more than those teams can provide and it
might just start with a conversation you
know maybe you're at a conference and
meet up with somebody and say hey we
yeah we have these sort of things I
still feel like it's pretty organic how
a lot of these engagements start also
with the packages I mean like and I
think you're a hundred percent correct
like we're constantly trying to generate
reusable content right like these
reusable packages but like we found it
hard in the sense of that every customer
is unique it's amazing like they're
using different flavors of code and
different flavors of os is in different
network so I've been in cloud a long
time and there are like Pat common
patterns but it's amazing how many
different combinations you see and when
you're doing an engagement what sort of
hands-on engagement are you having there
I mean are you sitting down and building
out architecture diagrams are you
sitting next to your engineers and
writing code or yeah I think it's a
little bit of everything
sometimes the engagements are short so
with security we have just a security
workshop so we'll go into a customer for
around three days and do a lot of
security deep dives into our services a
lot of best practices kind of tutorials
whiteboarding then we have customers who
want more of the come in
how to move this from the data center
beams to containers in TCP and that
might be coming up with a technical
design document so it's writing out a
lot of use cases and diagramming that
but then there also might be that case
where it's like hey this is great you've
diagrammed all the source and delivered
this technical design document but we
really need help implementing that so
then we might have another engagement
where we do that we also leverage
partners to help with some of this work
so if there's a lot of hands on keyboard
or they want more staff on we tend to
instead of having Googlers set a company
months on 10 we use partners to do that
yeah I would say absolutely I mean
Google has never traditionally been a
consulting company like you don't think
of Google as a consulting company so
we're definitely partner heavy but we do
try to mimic some of the success Google
has had internally at our larger
projects so for example we have a TPM
that maps to a TL that maps to partner
engineers and we try to explain those
acronyms just for those who want
Googlers Auto Show Technical Program
Manager TL is the technical lead that's
how we develop our products internally
and so we've had a lot of success
mimicking that model at some of our
larger customers and then we're able to
iterate faster everything is documented
and we're you know status reporting well
and another added kind of layer of
complexity that we see is that we're not
just GCP right we're G suite we're
chrome we're Android so like that adds
just another layer of I wouldn't say
complexity but you know when they go
all-in on Google it's like they get
access to all these different things and
it's kind of interesting how you can
really transform a business not just
from a technical staff but like from a
peoples in process so that's something
new that we've been working on as well
so you guys are on the front lines
you're hanging out with customers you're
learning things you're helping folks any
trends or changes that you're seeing
that you find particularly interesting
one of the trends we're seeing a lot is
multi cloud so you have customers to
have been an AWS or sure for a while but
then they see things that we're doing
that maybe the other cloud providers
aren't doing they're just doing it
differently so we're seeing customers
coming to us or gke or I see customers
come
to us for all our ML technologies but
then maybe they continue to use the
other cloud providers for other things
and I also I think really in the last
year it's been a big uptick in gke or
kubernetes a lot of companies now it's
like if we're moving to the cloud we
just want to move to containers we don't
want to deal with VMs anymore
again I can concur like being an
old-school BSD person you know and as an
infrastructure lead I mean
infrastructure historically is compute
network storage right and now you know
they're beginning to abstract all that
away into this like open source cloud I
mean that's what ORS gets on says we're
the open source cloud and therefore
we're moving away from VMs and and this
type of thing and we're going to
containers gke sto service meshes and so
the long term vision I believe of GCP is
to be the open source cloud you can run
your compute here you can move it on
Prem can move data around so there's a
lot more I guess a momentum to that
direction I mean companies want to get
there because they kind of don't want to
be tied to a cloud provider right they
want their freedom and I believe GCP is
moving that direction right we're trying
to just like open it up you want to use
GCP great you want to run on Prem go
right ahead that's great are you seeing
any particular GCB products that are
like super hot right now CSP and I wish
I knew this is it and you know
ironically you know Eric Brewer an old
professor of mine is kind of leading the
charge here it's just the open source
cloud it's containers is tio and now
we're extending it out in that you can
extend kind of like the kubernetes
language that's in llamó
deployment language and now you can
extend it out to further GCP services so
now I can start defining pub subtopics
and cloud sequel databases all within
this kubernetes constructs so I'm super
excited to see that happen and yeah and
you seeing anything in particular with
your customers I think what I'm seeing
it's not so much hot services because
I've been talking to customers who are
really wanting security first I think
the trend is really to get the security
teams at the table from the beginning
I think a year ago and six months ago
we'd have customers who plan all these
deployments for like we're ready to go
to reduction and then all of a sudden
they get a big red flag they're like no
because the security teams weren't
brought in from the beginning so I'm
really seeing a passion from customers
about getting the security folks to the
table first and coming from a security
background I'm very happy to see this
and just making security part of the
deployment pipeline baking security in
from the beginning so they don't have to
think about it later on absolutely I
would say one more thing I'm seeing a
lot is very large data migrations and
I'm not talking about you know 10
terabytes or even 10 petabytes I'm
talking a hundred plus petabytes and so
the new challenges for the
infrastructure team is how do I even
move this data around right I know there
are some products that you come in and
plug a fiber in and you're supposed to
you know close your eyes and pray that
all the data gets copied but it's just
much more than that right because you're
applying security policies to the data
you're encrypting it and this amount of
data I think I did an analogy in a
presentation saying we're moving so much
data as some of our customers if you
were to stack the hard drives up it
would be higher than like three Golden
Gate bridges or something like it's
massive amounts of data and I think this
is fairly new that I haven't experienced
to date why are they doing that servers
go end-of-life right I mean they're
running these gigantic Hadoop clusters
NetApp filers I mean they just go
end-of-life and then now they're faced
with how do I make use of this data like
I need to obviously run MapReduce or
parallel process it and so I think it's
a combination of end-of-life and the new
frontier of AI like they want to happen
to google's AI for the data and the only
way to do that obviously is to have the
data in cloud but again it's like
totally new challenges I mean you don't
just are sync or FTP to data up you know
given that you work so much with
customers you mentioned previously that
you work a lot with product managers as
well is that sort of shaping product and
providing feedback what does that
internal stuff look like yeah so there's
a lot of that so I work closely with a
lot of the security PM so Andy Chang CJ
Johnson Mya
so it is giving feedback I must have
been contributing to some of the PCI
Work and compliance work we're doing and
we also do sessions at next the cloud
summits we lead internal and what we
call Samia academies so it's leveling up
a lot of the folks that are in the field
so PSO the customer engineers solution
architects on security so we do this a
couple times a year bring a lot of the
security PM's and other folks to talk
about roadmaps what's going on on the
field so we're all kind of on the same
page and I've been helping build out
some demos for the products that we have
so again that's partnering with Sandy a
lot so yeah there's a lot of exciting
things going on but I really love the
fact that were able to feedback into the
products and give and put into what's
being built I would say I have a
love-hate relationship with product
managers let me explain it I mean we
mostly love each other but back to this
you know when you're migrating 200
petabytes to a storage platform there's
a lot of things to consider and so what
we do is like as a TPM I'm basically
negotiating between product management
and the customer right and it's this
constant on.you negotiation and like we
drive product like for example the dual
bucket GCS feature that I believe now is
in beta came from a customer saying okay
I'm gonna have you know my hundred
petabytes in u.s. East won and if I have
a regional outage and I have a security
event I mean to go through this data
like what am I supposed to do so there's
this new dual region bucket that came
out of that requirement another example
is the customer said okay I want to
process this hundred petabytes in like
20 minutes right and you do the math and
it's like you know I need 20 terabytes a
second of throughput that's like
completely outrageous so you know I was
able to like work with the security team
and the customer to kind of like back
that down to something like reasonable
so that's where the love hey I mean they
love me when I'm negotiating with the
customer and basically saving the
platform but they hate me when I'm
demanding new features right but this is
ongoing any big customer it's exciting
right product managers always want to
partner with that PSL people yeah but
those features sound amazing and it's so
cool that they're driven by really
use cases that we're running into that
and solving problems for people that are
on our platform that's awesome
absolutely I mean like if you were to
tell me I could have like petabytes and
petabytes of data asynchronously copied
to two locations at the same time like I
don't know how they do it well I do know
how they do it but we have we have big
pipes yeah it's pretty amazing very big
pipes and lots of magic rpms
they're super busy they are always very
eager to speak to customers and present
to customers I'm in awe sometimes how
they get everything done that they do
just to add on I mean the platform is
changing so rapidly that literally my
full-time job should just be like
monitoring new beta features I try to
set up an RSS feed but that didn't
really work
you know like I'm trying to figure out
like a good way to digest all this
information so if any users out there I
have a good method of doing this I hear
this podcast is really good for that
yes listening to podcasts like you know
like 24 hours a day know if you ran 30
miles you can listen to podcasts so
we've heard about some of the cool and
challenging problems you've run into any
others you want to share with us because
I know everyone loves hearing about all
the other cool problems that other
people have I'll even speak for an on
this one like you're getting Oh No yeah
getting ready to roll to production like
you're ready to click the button and
just say go and then the seaso walks ins
is like what's going on right and you're
like oh I'm migrating like all our
infrastructure to cloud and then he puts
a kibosh on the whole thing because like
obviously it hasn't gone through the
proper like security reviews and audits
and compliance and I mean you know
that's a true story and that's a true
story over and over again but I think
now that we have the security practice
and some of our our sales teams and our
technical account managers know that
they're trying to get security at the
table to begin with and so we have
unblocked a couple of these scenarios
just by having security folks in the
room and regardless of the security
folks were part of the infrastructure
team two months ago but because they
have that security title it's helped and
again it's just trying to automate
security into the work flow to begin
with
having it almost seamless and you see
you don't have to think about it
actually yeah you say automating
security of any particular tools or
products that you really liked for doing
that kind of stuff what I like right now
and I always end up saying this
incorrectly but for containers is using
your face and krita's for signing using
that with binary authorization so you
can set policies to check for multiple
different things but you know for
different vulnerabilities vulnerability
scores if they're high or medium or so
forth and if those are found then the
kree discussant sign the container image
and if you go and try to deploy it it
gets stopped so I think that's pretty
neat tool that we have out there right
now
so binary authorization is in GCP and
graffia s-- and kritis and again i'm
sorry if i said that correctly we'll put
links in the show notes we'll work it
out open source projects we have you
have your technical issues and I think
probably more importantly you have your
people issues and like it's generally a
people issues that kind of like provide
like the roadblock right and so in
larger migrations you're like navigating
emotions you know like I'm almost a
psychiatrist at these projects right
like I'm coaching them about like their
cloud migration and coaching them about
like how to retrain their org and it's a
lot of pressure right you have to
retrain people maybe some people might
lose their jobs as a result of some of
the migrations so there's a lot of
people aspects to our job I've got a
challenging one they've got an
architecture diagram from miles ward
miles wart hands them something
beautiful it's amazing it's AI it's
automated it's dr like you know half the
world can get hit by a meteor and this
thing would still run you know it's like
they get handed this and they're like
yes i want it then you go in there and
they're running like windows 95 right so
that can be challenging they know what
they want they want the big picture and
the the beautiful googliness and then
you know it's it's just kind of hard to
get them there and so reality can be
tough sometimes but we're there to
iterate them and like kind of help them
out right so first of all hi miles
second of all how do you step people
through that like how do you how do you
take someone from from somewhere where
they're in a less modern architecture
and bring them up to speed and what may
native or whatever the the buzzword is
right now we're working on a partner
package well a package that basically
takes them the first step to container
so you can run a container an
orchestration system like kubernetes ray
and orchestrates you know multiple
containers and load balances and does
all that fun stuff but you can also run
a container in a one-to-one mapping to
actual VM so like I'm working on a
package that says okay I'm going to take
your VM and containerize it which gets
you then you can use the tools that Ann
mentioned to kind of do the security and
get it in a registrar and then you're
going to deploy these containers on a
one-to-one mapping to GCE so now your
container rise but you're still kind of
running on a lift and ship mode so
that's like a initial step and then
security comes in and you get all the
features you know like gob for example
offers I believe it has like DDoS and
other things like that and actually I
have something that's a little
interesting I don't know if it's an
interesting problem that we've solved
but I think it's something different
that PSO does and maybe other cloud
professional services organizations and
just slipped my mind because I've been
so focused on security but when I
started at Google I was helping build
out CRE offerings with PSO so I think
you've had some of the CRE folks on the
podcast before and so CRE just for folks
who might not have heard that is
customer reliability engineers so they
are some of our site reliability
engineers who are customer facing and
work with some of our larger customers
on building out asari practices within
their org the CRE team is small and just
overbooked so they were looking to see
how they could grow this so they've
partnered with PSO so we're starting to
offer CRE off rain so some of this is
just going in and doing kind of basic
SRA 101 but then we also have SLO SLI
workshops so this is you know taking a
customer's application and running
through what it might look like to set
error budgets and your SLO s and s
allies so the little bit I got to work
on that six or so months ago was really
exciting but it's starting to kick off
now so there's a few folks within PSO
who are driving that so I'm really
excited to see where that that goes
just to follow up there I can't believe
I forgot the sorry portion of all this
you know I partnered with Liz Fong Jones
one of my favorite people on earth it's
actually like a new construct so I came
from another large cloud vendor and we'd
lift and shift and we'd lift and
transform but we never talked about
operations right and so again this is
coming with the whole I want to run like
Google so you can lift and shift the
monolith and actually apply you know sre
principles to these monolith
applications so we're doing that as well
so we're trying to kind of embed this
during the transition you know it's just
a whole lot of fun you know when you
start talking about error budgets and
you know how many nines you know you
know the customer asks for five nines
but the application they have is two 9s
it's like it opens up for some
interesting conversations so if people
want to get involved with all this
awesome work you're doing in PSO where
do they go they visit us at Google next
or you know they talked to their GCP
counterparts the CEO or the sales team
the Technical Account Managers like you
know we're all tied together like one
Google right so you know we're like a
large hashmap cloud.google.com I think
you can find us on there we have tons of
job openings I think you could just look
for cloud consultant it'll come up with
things in infrastructure app dev
Security ml so it sounds like if people
want to get in contact with you best
ways through their account rep or their
sales contact if they want to get into
contact with PSO yeah I can tell you how
to personally get in contact with me but
you yeah you can save me an email but
like I'm you know have thousands and
thousands of emails unread at this point
but we are running out of time
unfortunately is there anything you both
want to mention are you doing anything
special for next or something that you
want to make sure people know about
anything along those kind of lines
before we finish up today yeah I will be
it next I'm not speaking this year I'm
just gonna be hanging out talking about
security right after next on this April
13th is a women who code Connect summit
so I'll be speaking there that is also
in San Francisco and the cube con EU
speakers just got announced so I'm gonna
be speaking with Maya and we are going
to be speaking about container forensics
when your cluster becomes a cluster that
sounds cool can I go where is it
Barcelona oh yeah yeah I will be
attending that well thank you so much to
you both for joining us here on the
podcast we really appreciate you taking
the time thanks a lot thanks for having
us
bye thanks so much to N and Michael
coming to hang out with us it's always
really interesting to hear about team's
internal to Google how they help
customers and how they help support them
so super happy to have them on yeah that
was a great chance to talk and learn
about something that I didn't actually
know much about yet but now it is time
for a question of the week
and our question this week has to do
with cloudbuilt and the question is how
do you cache files between builds and
cloud build which is something that a
lot of folks want to do to speed up
their builds and or because they've got
interesting pipelines that they're
trying to build where they have lots of
different dependencies so mark what is
the answer to this question I had
exactly this problem basically I had a
file-based case that I wanted to store
some records in and just persist it
between builds to make things a bit
faster you know I was like okay clearly
I have Google Cloud storage I can push
stuff up and down but like what if it's
not there what if it is I don't want to
write all this code so I went hunting
through the repository which is the
cloud builders community repository
under Google cloud platform which has a
bunch of Google Cloud builder steps
these are custom build steps that you
can use yourself inside cloud build that
do some kind of fancy things and there's
a whole bunch of them I'm not gonna go
through them all but one of them that
stands out and one that I really like is
there is a case build step or a cache
depending on with your Australian or
American and what it has it has a safe
cache and a restore cache functionality
so it will take basically any path that
you like and check it in Google Cloud
storage
you can have keys you can have your own
keys if you want you can tell what
bucket you want to put into it'll even
do checksumming of a particular file so
if you want the case to be stored with
the checksum of a file and you want it
to change with the file change it's all
kind of baked in and just works so if
you're looking for that we'll put a link
in the show notes but it's super handy
just put it in it's just where it was
great yeah and that whole community all
those community supplied buildings are
really great because oftentimes the
problems we have a problem someone else
has already solved and we're really
grateful the community for the ones that
they've contributed so even if caching
isn't your problem you should totally go
check out the community builders
repository on github and see what other
folks have built awesome well before we
wrap up what are you doing where are you
going do anything cool I'm not doing
anything cool I am taking a break from
travel and events to focus on family and
my career and a bunch of other you know
really boring stuff awesome good for you
so I'm gonna be online if people want to
see what I met too they can totally
check out my blog at psycho miser comm
or they can follow me on Twitter I am
duh underscore ithaca miser and for
those who don't know if AGGA miser is
the spiky part at the end of a
Stegosaurus
I've got blog posts that are written and
going to be released in the next couple
weeks on doing coding assessments and
interviews this what we can do instead
whiteboards because there's been a bunch
of tweets recently about whiteboards
being awful and then I'm getting I have
a horrible project idea that I'm going
to use with Ruby and GCP and cloud
storage and probably some of the ML API
is that I hope to have a blog post about
in the next couple weeks that folks can
check out especially all of my Ruby
friends and new versions of Ruby was
just released
Ruby Hagee and I'm gonna check out
pattern matching has been added as a
potential future I'm gonna check that
out because I love me some pattern
matching so Betsy if you curious about
my thoughts on any of those things
follow me online see how about you mark
where are you gonna be going what are
you gonna be up to yeah so in what two
three weeks I will be a Google i/o I'll
be doing the presentation there about
open match in taganas working together
games on top of guru Nettie's and open
source unsurprisingly I'll mention
something that's a little bit further in
the future as well in August there is an
open sourcing gaming day so people may
be familiar with the open source North
America summit under the Linux
Foundation we've been working with them
and some other people looking to
advocate for more open source in the
games industry so we're gonna have a day
that's August 20th it's co-located with
the event so it's gonna be the day
before so if you are interested in
attending we'll have details in the show
notes but if you have any particular
open source stories around anything
pretty much to do with gaming there is a
call for papers open as well till May
4th I believe that dates correct I will
also have the link in the show notes as
well so that'll be fun that's coming up
in August that sounds awesome
cool well as yeah I think that wraps
things up yeah so thank you all for
listening we'll have another awesome
episode for you next week see you all
next week
[Music]